[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host rachel
cruz ramsey personality number one new
york times best-selling author multiple
times and my daughter is my co-host
today we'll be answering your questions
about your life and your money open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five the advice is free and
some say it's worth every penny
triple eight eight two five five two two
five arnell is gonna start us off in
california hey arnel what's up in your
world
hello it's a pleasure speaking with you
you've
shed some light on my life i'm very
excited about it
basically paying off our mortgage that's
where we are and building wealth nice
so my question is we are about ready to
sell
a piece of real estate which we've owned
for 30 something years
and it will go for 1.5 million
approximately we've just got our first
offer
and we split that with my brother-in-law
since we co-own it
with that money let's just say 700 000
we're going to pay off another rental
property and our primary residence and
then we'll have about five hundred
thousand dollars left i hate it when
those are
i know
[Laughter]
we are
65 and 68 so we're in that stage of our
life and we're not quite sure what to do
with that money
what do you suggest
so that means you're baby step seven
you're millionaires
and you've done it you're good shape
you've you're completely debt free and
you got an extra half million dollars
that you just have to figure out what to
do well you address it to dave's cabo
fund
and you send it no i'm kidding okay
why are the money to the cayman i
started writing
[Laughter]
i'm so proud of you guys well done
arnelle
do you feel like do you feel
accomplished because you should
i i do i came from nothing you know
inner city projects in new york and
we've really done well so i'm very
excited what were your careers
currently we both own our own business
my husband and i are both prosthetists
so we make artificial limbs for amputees
wow and
then i have been a special ed teacher
i've been a homeschooling mom
a prosthetist and now i own my own
gluten-free organic baking mix company
which i am about to sell wow
yeah nothing's stopping you that's
amazing
all right well there's only three things
you can do with money that's give it
enjoy it
and invest it so that you can give it
and enjoy it
and so we always recommend with money
that's laying around
that you are intentional with it that
you give it a give it an
assignment
uh before it gets there
because if it gets there and you don't
give it an assignment it can slip away
and so you say we're going to enjoy
by going on a trip or buying some item
or some lifestyle decision some of this
money and it's x number of dollars and
we're going to buy this thingy with it
or whatever it is you write it down and
we're going to uh we're going to be
generous with it we're going to find
some people that
need some help
like where you came from
and you say we're going to help them get
started we're going to help them with
their life whoever that is and that's
outrageous generosity and
then we're going to uh obviously invest
some of it
and you can buy a piece of paid for real
estate which is what i do or and or you
could
invest in good mutual funds which is
what i do
but
what a great story no it's amazing
arnold do you guys have kids
yes we have two daughters
and two grandkids maybe two
okay any grandkids not yet not yet okay
no grandkids yet but for your two
daughters yep that's wonderful well i
mean i mean i feel like that this is
always just oh go ahead
i have a question about um index
annuities
somebody was telling me that one called
like american national it's like a fixed
index
flexible premium that has this range but
you can never lose the money if the
market crashes
any thoughts about that yeah there's uh
yeah i wouldn't do fixed annuities but a
variable annuity might be a play and it
does give you a protection of principle
and it'll even give you a floor on a
minimum it will make however their fees
are higher
and so
you're going to pay more fees there than
if you buy a mutual fund and basically
they're going to require in most cases
that you leave the money in there long
for a long period of time or otherwise
you're going to have surrender charges
and if you have the surrender charges
then um
uh
you know if you had left it alone five
years in a mutual fund it wouldn't have
gone down anyway
on average that's why they're able to
make that guarantee so
i'm 60 i don't have any variable
annuities but i'm not worried about the
stock market i'm not worried that i'm
going to lose money i'm going to ride
out any downturns from there is there
ever a time frame to do
a variable annuity this would be it if
you were going to do it uh it's the only
time only after your home is paid for
and all your other retirement stuff's
maxed out uh and it grows tax deferred
it sits in there and grows
but again you don't really have good
access to it and the guarantee that it
makes
you know if you look at the historical
data on what the stock market actually
does actually does
you don't really need that guarantee if
you're gonna leave alone five years or
seven years right use that right so
you're gonna get you're gonna make a
floor of 5 or more
if you didn't it'd be the first time in
the history of the market you're going
to get your you're going to at least
make your principal but if you want to
sleep a little bit better and you don't
you know you want that guarantee i'm not
mad about it i i'm okay if people buy
these i don't want you buying them
for your iras and stuff like that
because that stuff's already
got stuff got you know it's already
built in
and so um we don't need to do principal
protection on that stuff but if you want
to with this some of this money that's
fine but i think the thing i want you to
leave with our now is
you should do all three things with the
money
i don't care what the amounts are but
you need to spend some on you
and sometimes people like you don't do
that enough
you've done a great job we hear that a
lot especially people that have
sacrificed and have worked
decades literally and i mean she's in
southern california right even true i
mean
it's so her i mean if her house is paid
for there you know it's been a long time
that you know they've put money towards
you've been diligent and then to be able
to look up and actually have the freedom
to spend it's like
it's a muscle you have to learn to grow
if you haven't already yeah and
sometimes the generosity muscle
outrageous generosity
you know sometimes people think
generosity is five bucks no not not when
you're sitting on that kind of money
that's not generosity that's cheap
so no i mean you need to find about
about five or six single moms and buy my
car
you know or something like that yeah
that kind of thing you need to have some
fun with the generosity piece of this
and get all down in somebody's business
and really help them
and um
you know we've all had people help us
over the years in different ways
sometimes it was encouragement sometimes
it was an actual dollar amount
uh but that's that's why you do this and
so make sure you're doing all three
things with this but you've done such a
good job so proud of you this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier
ziprecruiter is rated the number one job
site in the us by g2 and it's free so
how does it work
first go to ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's
ziprecruiter.com
can sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today she is the author of the
new bestseller know yourself know your
money new york times bestseller discover
why you handle money the way you do and
what to do about it the know yourself
money assessment
is uh 20 for individuals 30 for couples
great for couples who want to get on the
same page you get your money profile and
beliefs your money classrooms how you
grew up your money tendencies and fears
and motivations and attitudes and
actions it all prints out and you will
look at your spouse and go oh that's why
you do that
so be sure and check all that out no
parent ever wants their child to
experience the panic of being unprepared
for an emergency well we've got your
back with our digital self-study courses
for teenagers you can rest assured that
your teen will know the right way to
handle money no matter what curveball's
life can throw them best part is no
instructors needed if your teen has a
tablet or a computer they're all set
parents text self-study to 33 789
self-study to 33789
and you can learn more about the
different courses we have for middle
school and for high school you'll see
rachel cruz featured on most all of
those jimmy is with us jimmy is in st
louis hi jimmy welcome to the ramsey
show
hey dave hey rachel thanks for taking my
call sure
what's up i am
uh
basically just laid out there i'm 27
years old um i have no debt other than a
mortgage
i bought this house back in march and i
have about 49 000 left on it wow um
i have a home repair that set me sent me
back from step six to step three um
i'm currently sitting on about thirty
thousand individual stocks outside of
401k
and uh i'm just kind of i'm trying to
figure out what to do with it do i
replenish my emergency fund and reinvest
the rest of it
uh just pour the rest of it back into my
mortgage
do i reinvest all the
these stocks with mutual funds um
i'm just wanting to get your take on it
yeah our general rule of thumb is always
not to own individual stock because
majority of your of your net worth and
so i mean we always say you know
if all your eggs are in one basket right
i mean just the idea of diversification
is so much better when it comes to
investing so like you said mutual funds
is the best way to go in that case so if
i were you i would yes cash out those
individual stocks
replenish baby step three and then go
right back down to the baby steps which
would mean a lot of that probably will
be in baby step six for you especially
if you've maxed out
baby step four already all of your
retirement what's this house worth
uh
i bought it at about seventy thousand it
ended up uh having to have a few repairs
the appraisal came in at like 80.
so good for you
okay so what do you make
i make
us
about 58 after taxes okay so what is the
uh how much does it take to replenish
the emergency fund
um
probably another eight thousand i i'm
gonna try so i would put eight thousand
and that and twenty two thousand on the
house
okay and then you're going to be done
with your house in under three years
exactly what rachel said
okay
yeah that just walking right down the
baby steps you replenish that emergency
fund and then just lean in on that house
dude you're so close and you're as young
as you are you're in great shape you
have done a fabulous job touchdown baby
good job jeremy's with us in oklahoma
city hi jeremy welcome to the ramsey
show
hey david rachel how are you great how
can we help
yeah i'm a second lieutenant in the air
force uh and i'll be promoting to first
lieutenant here in september
my wife and i have been loosely
following the baby steps
we just moved from
pensacola florida to oklahoma so we had
some moving expenses we had to save up a
little bit more than a thousand dollars
to start with
um in the apartment we got here in
oklahoma it's kind of inadequate and we
were ready for a house so we sort of
jumped the gun a bit and bought a house
when we still had about 5 500 left to
pay on my truck but that's our only debt
so i guess my question is now that we
have a house and more can go wrong would
you suggest throwing everything
available at the truck to go ahead and
get it paid off or increasing the
initial emergency fund before we
hey off that truckload
jeremy i'm just curious what what about
the situation for you guys were you guys
in a house in florida and then you moved
to an apartment and you just kind of got
restless i'm just curious kind of the
the why behind that decision to jump the
gun you guys were just kind of
discontent
sure thing uh so we just got married in
december we were in an apartment in
florida uh which really we actually
really liked and then the apartment we
got that was available when we got to
oklahoma uh you know air force moves us
when they decide to move us
um the only thing we could find was was
not the best um this is the example our
apartment smelled like wheat all the
time neither of us smoke it was just
seeping in from the walls of our
neighbors basically
and then there were some some issues
where we were having
trouble getting maintenance done in the
apartment
uh the maintenance guy lives next door
and he was high all the time
and as part of part of our military pay
we do get a housing allowance and we
were able to find a we were able to find
a house that was within that housing
allowance yeah we're in a 30-year fixed
va loan
and as i said i'm going to promote here
in september
so my my take-home pay yeah after taxes
will increase by about a thousand
dollars a month and how much will that
how much will that be a year
um so right now before the before the
promotion it's about 50 000 a year after
tax
uh so it'll be up to about
uh
60 000 a year
after tax and that's just my income my
wife also another reason we decided to
jump the guns my wife just got a job on
base right now she's making 12 33 an
hour but it fluctuates from 20 to 40
hours a week so we didn't
factor that into a budget my my income
pays for all of our expenses
okay
okay so the rule of thumb when it comes
to buying a house the reason why we
always say to wait is because probably
what you're learning pretty quickly is
that owning a home is expensive right
it's not just the purchase of the home
it's everything else that kind of goes
into play but whether you're a homeowner
or not
still focusing on the debt and getting
that truck paid off as soon as possible
is going to be your main focus so i
would not up the emergency fund
keep it at a thousand and if something
comes up and you have to pause paying
off the truck to save up to fix
something in the house then that's what
you have to do but besides that
still attacking that 5 500 and then
building up that emergency fund so so
again the reason for everyone listening
is that when you still have debt and you
don't have a lot of savings and you buy
a home and something does break it just
makes the whole situation stressful it's
more of a curse
um than a blessing of what a house
should be it just doesn't bring that
peace so for you guys i would just say
jeremy to make that be extra motivation
to be like all right we're gonna get
this truck paid off fast we're gonna get
some cash in the bank to save up more so
that we're not kind of ugh because you
you feel it you said we're jumping we
jumped the gun a little so you're
feeling a little bit of that stress i
know
so thank you for your service
um i think rachel's right but listen
listen dude here's the thing
okay
you're screwing around with this stuff
you're running around making up your own
rules and in your head what you did was
smart and it wasn't smart
you did it out of order yes you jumped
the gun but you're not concerned about
jumping the gun and you should be
you screwed up
and so don't screw up again
decide you're going to work these baby
steps exactly and with military-like
discipline
one thousand dollars is baby step one
beans and rice rice and beans i don't
wanna see your butt in a restaurant
until you get this truck paid off unless
you're working there's your extra job
and the fact that you're making more
money is not an excuse to be stupid and
it's not an excuse to get things out of
order so you gotta tighten up man
and uh it's time to do that now you can
do that or you cannot do that you're a
grown guy you get to decide what you're
gonna do but you called here and asked
us what to do and so what you're going
to get is a proven plan that millions of
people have done you don't need to fix
this it's not broken
you need to just execute on it
exactly
and with discipline and so the fact you
know all the people most the people
working baby steps one through three
have a house
and they all start with baby step one
being a thousand dollars yeah
but what you're feeling in your gut is
the fear of something breaking in that
house and to rachel's point that's
exactly why you shouldn't have bought
the stupid house because you're broke
and when broke people buy houses stuff
in their house breaks that's how this
works that's why they call them mortgage
brokers and real estate brokers it gets
you broker and broker
and it's not a blessing so you know you
need to roll up your sleeves and tear
your tear into this thing man tear into
it and get that car gone get that
emergency fund built by christmas get it
done
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225
[Music]
right here in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage james
and megan are with us hey guys how are
you hey we're good how are you better
than we deserve welcome and all the way
from where do you live
charlotte north carolina to do a
debt-free screen
how much did you pay off
249 756.57
ding ding ding
way to go
how long did this take
three years three months and 20 days wow
that's a lot in a fast yeah what's your
household income during that time the
range um it ranged it started at about
120 and um
we're on track to probably clear a
little over is 165 000 now excellent way
to go what do you all do for a living
i'm a project manager
and a real estate and a real estate
agent on the side um i'm a um deployment
engineer
okay excellent software so what kind of
debt was the 250 000 everything
uh we had medical bills we had credit
cards car
student loans student loans was most of
it my fault
okay wow how long y'all been married
uh almost five years almost in october
it will be so not long after marriage
you look up and go oh my god there's a
lot of dad we gotta do what happened
tell us the story our daughter was born
oh
that'll die baby a baby does it that's a
wake-up call
yeah no pun intended
some of us were dragging our feet a
little more than others
um but um
i came home one day and uh she said i
paid off the medical debt from our
daughter and i said how did you do that
we didn't we didn't have that money and
she said uh that credit card that the uh
the bank gave me um that's connected to
the house equity um i paid it with that
and i said you did what this
medical debt had no interest and you
just put it on something that's got
interest
and i ran into the office grabbed the
paper shredder going down the middle of
the floor and we had a shred party right
there in the middle whoa
a debit card got shredded in the process
too
anything that was plastic yeah the whole
driver slices everything yeah
oh my gosh i was yeah i was done yeah
okay oh man it sounds like a big fight
oh yeah there was there was more than
a water bill got paid on it yeah for you
it was just hey i'm gonna try to help
that's right the process you said you
didn't know it was a little bit of an
ignorance absolutely yeah yeah okay so
the meltdown and the the famous shred
night and then what happens
and then um we my dad actually had
purchased um financial piece for me
years ago and it was on the shelf
so that came out and we started the
journey on our own oh wow then we um we
found a church group that was doing one
and we went and and did it with the
church group and wow we became
coordinators and started teaching our
own classes to kind of keep ourselves
accountable that'll do it and um we're
still doing classes today nothing like
teaching something to make sure you
learn it oh yeah
wow wow where'd it go you guys yeah yep
now we're uh three uh we're doing three
and we're on to uh four five and six wow
amazing so well done yeah how does it
feel great it's like a
giant weight lifted off my shoulders i
when i graduated college with all that
debt i honestly thought i would never
i was i was hesitant to get married have
kids
because i saw this massive amount of
debt and i was like i don't want to put
this on anybody else and i'll never pay
this off
and then when i met her i was like well
i can't let her go
and so i got married and i figured we're
gonna figure out how to get through this
and then so it was like 200 grand in
student loan debt oh yeah yeah he went
private school cross country oh yeah
just a whole whole enchilada baby yeah
megan actually called your show i did oh
what did i say was that nice after you
were nice you were surprising on some of
the stuff you said but um
we got a call from
i didn't warn her about my student debt
and they called her because i was
delinquent on a lot of it and they said
um we're willing to settle a hundred and
twenty thousand of it for eight thousand
dollars
and yeah on student loans yeah did they
do it they did it i called you oh it's
all private it's all private okay okay
yeah and but what they did is they took
the they took the principal balance and
they took 10 of the principal balance
and settled for the 10 of the principal
balance wow and we did it we got it all
in writing she called you you told her
yeah do this deal before they changed
her mind yeah um she said we didn't have
a credit card at the time we didn't have
eight grand at the time we didn't have a
grand at a time so she said you know
should we get a credit card to do this
and you explained like yes today you
have a hundred you know 120 000 on debt
tomorrow you have eight grand and an irs
issue
right um and
it's totally worth it i mean i can't i
can't tell anybody enough if if you're
hesitant about this or you think you're
doing dave ish or any of this stuff
you know
stop stop doing all that just go all in
and submit yourself to the process yeah
do it wow so you guys were newly parents
though new parents and you kind of
started this we are our two oldest um
are from a previous marriage oh okay
okay i'm sorry i'm sorry yeah but you
had had your daughter though which was
kind of the wake up
so what was the hardest part because i'm
like i know
it's it's hard right when you when you
have a new baby and you're trying to
figure out life it's expensive all of it
so what would be what would you say to
people that had their first baby and
they're realizing wow we got to get our
money in order yeah um i mean we we
really don't we we would go on family a
family vacation a year and we usually
went with like a parent and they kind of
helped us along the way um we would
budget to save for what we needed to
save everything but we really we didn't
really go out to eat we we just ate in
and we had beans and rice some nights
with the kids and yeah
like i mean our our children um you know
they they would only get to play like
one extracurricular activity a year like
we couldn't
do everything so they've sacrificed you
know right there with us but
um it's totally been worth the sacrifice
i mean it sucks seeing your friends and
other family members do all these
extravagant wonderful things but now
like we can go do those things
um only they're in debt and you're not
right that's right when we come home
from vacation we don't have to keep it
with us yeah it doesn't follow you home
that's right it's awesome i mean come on
guys
you know the key that i tell people is
contentment teamwork and focus
that's good and uh
if you can just do those things then you
can get through it i know it seems like
a lot but you can i promise you can get
through it yeah it's kind of a it's a
it's a contentment that goes
hey it's two years three years you can
do anything hold your breath for three
years and i went to college for three
years so i know i can do this for three
years
why not clean up college
wow amazing guys you guys are so i'm so
proud of you well done thank you who
were your biggest cheerleaders outside
the two of you
my dad was a big one yeah yeah
got the fpu kid off the shelf and blew
the dust off of it our our children were
big cheerleaders um because they knew at
the end of it
you know they
they get their own room and and we're
gonna you know work on getting that for
them
going on vacations and disney we've
promised disney at some point we're
gonna do that we got a budget for that
okay very good so fun well we got a copy
of the legacy journey for you that's the
next chapter in your story for sure
to being baby steps millionaires before
you know it you guys are right on track
well done well done well done you make
great money you got no payments you got
control teamwork contentment focus game
on man game on copy the total money
makeover too for you to give away to
somebody i'm sure you know somebody do
that away a lot thank you thank you
we'll let one of them be free from you
so thank you thank you very much well
done james and megan from charlotte
north carolina 250
000 dollars paid off in three years and
three months making 120 to 165.
count it down let's hear a debt-free
screen before we do this i want to thank
you and your team personally as well
thank you all right three
[Applause]
rachel somebody out there is looking on
their bookshelf and they see a dusty
financial piece university kit
and you need to pull it off right now
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today
number one best-selling author new york
times best-selling author of the latest
book
know yourself know your money discover
why you handle money the way you do and
what to do about it dan is in modesto
california hi dan welcome to the ramsey
show
thanks dave how you doing better than i
deserve how can i help
so i'm just having a little bit of
a
qualm right now with
trying to decide where to go okay um
i am a plumber right now as service
plumber i work on commission
because i found that really the
best places to work around here and make
decent money is uh to be on commission
based now that means 100 percent of my
income is commission okay i have no base
salary so my my
income varies very wildly
what's your worst money
my worst month was about uh 3 000 take
home what will it be in the next year
what will be your worst month in the
next year
um probably about 2 000 to 2500. why why
would you have a worse month than your
worst month ever so far and you've been
doing it a while
it should be bad well it
this is true okay so what's been your
best month
my best month has been uh eight thousand
take home
okay so three to eight thousand is your
range that we're working with right and
so that's wildly okay how much is your
rent yes
15.50 a month okay
and your question is what
so i've been trying to work extra to try
to it
to make sure that my worst months stay
as
minimal as possible meaning you know i i
don't have those bad months
uh the only problem with that is
i the way we do it is i work on call so
i would be on call over overnight or and
then on the weekends but if the calls
don't come in i don't really i don't get
paid anything for just being on call
right so i'm wondering should i continue
to work these extra shifts and you know
hope that the calls come in or should i
maybe look somewhere else where i would
be making much less per call because i
average you know if i'm actually working
on the weekends i average about 45 an
hour to 65 somewhere in there
depending on the job or should i take a
job making way less an hour
but it's guaranteed
dan where are you like when it comes to
debt savings like what you're just your
financial picture what does that look
like yeah so we've got about 54 000
total debt
um we're renting right now uh so we
don't have the mortgage and
we have we have a thousand our
thousand for baby step one in the
savings and then i've got a thousand in
the checking right now that i keep there
because i don't know what my next
paycheck is going to be so i want to
keep that just in case utilities are a
little high or something like that yeah
yeah
well when it comes to
understanding just the budgeting process
with a commission based um
i don't say salary because it's not
salary your own commission um
is is mapping out priorities
and so those first four things being
that rent
your utilities transportation and food
and so like these are the things that
absolutely have to be paid every single
month like we have to have money for
these things to survive
and then everything else under that i
would list in priority uh this is the
next this is the next thing we need next
next night all the way down
and the goal would be to get to a place
because there is such a swing for you
that on that you can live off of that
budget
that of okay if everything if we could
do everything we needed to right we
could live off this budget and then on
the months that we make more than that
we put we put it away and in a different
you know it could be in your checking
account it would i don't care what it is
for the down months you can pull from
that it's kind of that slush funds that
you're keeping month to month and people
that are on commission
there's a level of that that you need um
to be able to for that to be your safety
net so i would do that
and then
as regard to your question on which job
you should take if you do do the hourly
or
get a
lesser paying you know hourly position
somewhere else um i would map out i mean
on average how much are you making when
you're working overtime with that
plumbing company where you're making
more
and just see over maybe a three month
period
clocking exactly how much you're making
extra and then run the numbers that if
you're in a lower paying job how many
hours would you be working to make that
type and kind of just kind of like your
cost analysis yeah that's what i would
do here's what i'm hearing you didn't
grow up in a commission-based or
self-employed family
you grew up in a family that was
salaried
and so this is scaring your mom and dad
and it's scaring you because no because
you don't know how to emotionally
process these swings much less to how to
handle the math the math rachel just
told you how to do it with
prioritization
um and so
the way to back off and look at it is
this
everyone
is on straight commission
if you're on salary and you don't go to
work they quit paying you
they fire your butt right you know and
so you know everybody ultimately is on
straight commission and so the way
you've got to look at it is overall so
what i would do i heard a couple of
concerns one is i heard the
unpredictability's driving you nuts you
can't tell how much of the overtime and
how much of the on call to take and how
much not to take and you feel desperate
because of the volatility to take all of
it and it's keeping you working all the
time only you don't work all the time
because on call sometimes you're just
sitting there and you don't get the 45
bucks an hour
and so what i would do is say all right
i'm going to make a couple of
assumptions in my business model here
assumption is number one is i don't want
to work all the time
okay so how much do i want to work
and so you would take some over time
some on-call shifts but not as many as
you're taking now are not as many as
you're taking when you get good and
scared okay
and just say over the scope of a year i
want to work this many hours
okay now you're you're working 40 plus
these on calls right
correct okay and so if you're on call
you know you're you're
on call as much as 80 right
right so i would back that down and say
all right i got a wife a kid i got i got
a life and so i'm going to work some on
call plus my 40 and so i'm going to work
50 or i'm going to work 60 for the next
three years
and i'm just going to dial it up and
back until i get to that each you know
i'm going to take the premium extra 20
hours of on-call but not the not the
40-hour of on-call you don't have to do
that today if i'm going to do that as my
assumption what's my income probably
going to be and you can estimate that
very close you've got a lot of details
based on what you told me
and that is your household income or
that's your income for this career
and uh it sounds to me like that that's
about a 70 or an 80 000 a year job
that i just described
you have the ability to make 120 but
you're working an unreasonable number of
hours to get there so you're probably in
an 80 000 with some
ot some on call is that a fair guess
yes yeah so no you don't take a 40 000
year job when you're making 80
to get quote unquote stability because
what i just outlined really was
stability dan
that's a very predictable environment
that i just outlined and you can go do
that
so um
that's what i would do man i think but i
think you got to lay it out like that
and then you say all right what's the
minimum we've got to have every month to
eat and what rachel said you lay out
your priorities we call it the four
walls food shelter clothing
transportation and utilities before you
do anything else you lay that down
exactly in that order and then
everything else is listed
on a to-do list based on priority number
one is where all the money goes until
extra money past the four walls
until it's done then number two when
number two buckets full spills over to
number three when number three is full
spills over number four and that's how
you're going to work off your debt is
doing that now having done all of that
you may choose to crank it back up to 80
hours for a period of time as gazelle
intensity to attack that debt but at
that point you're doing it not out of
desperation due to the ins the emotional
insecurity of the variable income or the
unpredictability of it you're doing it
because we're attacking debt with a
system then
that's it i mean it's that's exactly it
the feeling which is very real
of holding your breath every month
thinking oh god we're gonna be able to
pay the bills we're gonna do it once you
have that plan in place and you're in
that formula that settles down
there you go
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books our thanks to james charles
our producer kelly daniel our associate
producer and phone screener i'm dave
ramsey your host and we'll be back
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
the ramsay show.com thanks for listening
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just 30 a
month get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over 70 dollars a
month by switching to pure top just go
to puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you jump in we'll talk about your life
your money
let's go to jim in st louis hi jim
welcome to the ramsey show what's up
hey dave long time listener first time
caller uh sure appreciate everything
that you do for people well thank you
especially me and my family i am
me and my wife are 58
and i am i've been in the oil and gas
industry for 34 years
and just going through getting a
severance package
that will pay me to the end of the year
and my question is i've talked to my
local financial advisor
and uh to bridge the gap to get to 59
and a half
so i can start drawing
my uh
2.3 million that i've saved because of
you way to go i didn't give you any of
it you did it
good job dude it was you it was you um
so uh
i just wanted to uh we we've got a
paid off house worth about
and don't know anything to anybody
and
look at your main question
my main question is to get through this
i've just been in this industry that has
been 24 7
and i'm just drained and
to take a break and and
and get through this next uh
16 months that i need to get to to uh to
reach that
that goal or that milestone of 59 and a
half what'd you do on the rigs
uh actually i i'm actually in more of a
retail oil and gas
i was a general manager
and
so that's that's where just the
corporate life has changed so much and i
and and i haven't and uh
it just was time to separate so i got
you i got no issue with that but you've
got all these years of experience can
you not contract and do something for 40
hours a week for 16 months
well i've got i've got a in order to get
the severance i've got
a two-year non-compete that pretty much
limits how much is your severance
uh it is four months
and how much is that
uh
35 000.
i wasn't very generous
okay
so
you gave up two years for
35 grand
pretty much yeah
i've got about
25 grand in roth that i can pull from
without a penalty
and
um
i had always
talked about or thought about doing some
real property
and uh
just never really got pulled the trigger
and
so i've got
some advice to to if i need to
to use like our home equity
to get by to the 59 and a half and then
once i get to there
you know that whatever we we have to use
from that you know that made me just
throw up a little didn't you
yeah i didn't make me too but i just i
was just the best i don't know who's
giving you that advice so i'd run from
them whoever they are they're an idiot
you're the guy with you're the guy with
over three million dollar net worth
not the idiot telling you to go get a
home equity loan
okay oh my god why don't you just get
something to do and earn a little bit of
income for a little bit
even if it's not even if it's not in
your field now i don't want you to go
work at walmart as a greeter that's not
what i'm talking about you're worth
three million dollars but but um
you know i mean it seems to me that
you've got a substantial amount of
skills that you could be a consultant to
someone in something
for a short period of time here and be a
very big help to them and maybe make 50
or 100 grand and just eat on that a
little bit and put your 25 with it and
work it through because you don't have a
dime liquid except your emergency fund
is that right
right i've got about 30
in in the
emergency fund and then i've got
25 yeah and then you got this 35
severance coming
correct yeah and so you got about 50
grand to work with
and so you need another 50 60 grand to
get through the six months right
or 16 months 16 months
yeah i mean your wife work outside the
home
yes she does what does she make
she makes uh 75. why can't y'all eat on
that man
yeah i mean that's why i'm saying i'm
not i'm i'm
i'm just really the conservative guy
and i just wanted to make sure that if i
don't do anything that i that we're
still okay obviously
we well you can make it it's gonna be
tight and it's gonna be a reduction in
lifestyle because you're used to making
bank
plus her 75. and now you got 35 and 20
plus her 75 plus whatever you can
scratch around and get as a consulting
gig until one of you hits 59 and a half
and you could begin a drawdown
but but i'm not going to tell you to go
borrow on your home equity loan dude
dance with a girl that brought you here
i'm with you
i'm with you i i
we put two girls through college they
they
made it out of college debt free and
we're just so proud of that and them and
uh
i'm proud of you man you're a freaking
hero
and last thing i want to see some hero
go get a home equity loan so i'll fight
you know but i and i i think what's
happening is too you're a little bit um
scarcely mindseted
no um you're so tired
um
i just hear emotional exhaustion
do i am i hearing that right
yes sir and so when i tell you hey just
go do some consulting you're like i
don't feel like getting out of bed
shut up man i finally got out of there
don't make me do that
[Laughter]
that's kind of what i'm hearing in your
spirit
and i think this is still fresh enough
so i'm gonna i'm gonna propose to you
that 90 days from now your emotions
probably will have healed a lot
and you'll be the other side of this
ptsd feeling and um
and i think you're the kind of person
that'll be a little bit bored at that 90
or 120 day mark
but right now you're still just kind of
walking wounded you got you're kind of
zombied
yeah am i wrong no you're right and uh
and do you want just permission
do you just want permission when you
called
was one of your main points do you just
want permission to be able to stay home
with the severance with your wife
working and that's okay like is that is
that one was that one of your basis of
your questions
um
yeah i'd say that was half of it
probably yeah if you want to and you all
can do that i'm okay with that yeah
i'm not okay with the home equity loan
and i'm really not okay with the [ __ ]
that told you to do that
so probably just called your best friend
a [ __ ] but i don't really care
no i i have uh everybody that knows me
like my middle name is dave
not not for real but that's how it could
be because uh i if i wouldn't for you
listen i'm not the hero in this story i
just talked about it on the radio you
went and did it
yeah but it wouldn't happen probably if
it wouldn't come for your encouragement
and everything and i can imagine how i
would feel if it wasn't for that well
you're in great shape you deserve to
take a lap you deserve to take a uh some
time in this with your feet in the sand
somewhere
and um
uh you know and just enjoy the ride and
certainly with 59 and a half i want you
to cash out about 100 grand and just go
do something fun uh you you've done a
wonderful job building wealth you're a
true baby steps millionaire you did
everything we teach true everyday
millionaire
and um
you know multi-millionaire uh and you
just ran out of steam
uh
about 16 months early that's all it was
and that's okay that's all right you
still are going to be fine
so yeah if you want to live on the
income that you have and the income as
rachel said you want permission live on
your wife's income and the 35 000 and
the 20 000 until the 59 and a half mark
hits i'm happy for you to do that if you
all can do that and you want to write
that out as your budget go do it
um i also think you probably could add
another 50 or 100 grand easy to the top
line of this thing uh working 20 25
hours a week consulting for someone
somewhere that wasn't a violation of
your non-compete
because you you've just done big stuff
for too long to not have the ability to
lend yourself to something if you want
to
but right now today you can't hear that
i can and i'm okay with that i've been
right where you are i've been so tired i
can't breathe
your lungs hurt you just look you know
it's just i get it uh so you're doing
good work man and you you did it
touchdown take a victory lap
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at
betheltech.net and get one thousand to
twenty five hundred dollars off of your
tuition again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage evan and jessica are
here hey guys
congratulations how much did you pay off
we got a 136
377. wow all right how long did this
take
three years
all right nice cool and your range of
income during that time
uh we started at 36 000 and we ended up
at 120. goodness gracious what do you
guys do for a living i'm a project
manager at a brand and software
development company cool uh military
awesome thank you for your service hey
thanks for your support very nice very
nice which branch uh army all right good
what was the 136 thousand dollars in
debt it was a lot
we had copious amounts of student loans
we had vehicles
we had wedding rings a mattress yeah
that was a thing you borrowed on
everything oh we did um you're like
normal
some may say that yeah
fun where do you guys live so we're
originally from kansas city uh metro
area but stationed up at uh fort knox oh
yeah
how long have you guys been married
five years five years okay so you went
two years into marriage just kind of
doing everything and then what happened
three years ago that he thought oh this
is not working so um
my aunt and uncle on my side they uh
were telling us their story about how
their they just got out of debt at our
grandmother's easter dinner and so on
the drive home we were like well okay
we're going into it let's look at some
podcasts and i actually
i did uh financial peace university
about uh
three years prior mm-hmm it didn't take
i'm sorry
i'm a repeater yeah it's fine um and so
on our drive home we're like i think we
can do this i think we can do this and
we just dug in and we we just went for
it um we were like we need to get debt
um before we start a family that was our
main goal oh um and uh so we we actually
did that because uh
we have a baby on the way so number
one's on the way
so
yeah congratulations thank you thank you
so um we shared that news with uh her
brother and uh sister-in-law and they
actually paid off their debt the next
day oh wow they had enough to just throw
it all on there so i'm all in boom we
can do that
but yeah we just we went gazelle intense
we just went for it wow wow okay so
you're newlyweds without kids
so the podcast gets it all started and
is that what you do you just listen to
the podcast over and over yeah we really
did and i attended uh we started a class
together for fpu but then we deployed
okay and then i did another class with a
friend of mine to get her started and
then we've recently led a class so
really just doing the classes but also
the podcast almost every day uh kept us
going and the debt free screams helped
us keep going too and and now you're
helping someone else keep going yeah
we're trying to get you well done so
proud of you guys thank you how does it
feel to be free
it feels amazing um our biggest push was
just changing our legacies uh both of us
come from families that didn't weren't
really responsible with money lost homes
went bankrupt and that was our biggest
motivator was we didn't want that for
our children um so yeah it's it's a huge
relief to go into a new family like this
yeah that's cool let's go a whole new
imprint yeah whole new family tree we're
trying to generational wealth it's fun
yeah and that's that's how it begins
somebody's got to start it might as well
be you right there you go i like it i
like it good for you guys well you tell
people now that you're coordinating a
class you paid off 136 000 in three
years what do you tell them the key is
communication and also organization
because once you just have that first
conversation together because we were
both so
do we talk about finances how do we talk
about it but then we were able to bring
you in
as like a third party to get mad at if
we needed to as far as decision making
went yeah
david i knew i had it
dave was a customer during our hospital
you see that sometimes
yeah
it really got us just on the same page
and then from there like he said we were
gazelle intense and it really just
helped us get aligned
absolutely amazing i was i was the free
spirit i didn't want to talk about it
at all so
but you engaged you did it
which is huge because that's a big part
of this whole journey it's very i mean
we rarely see married people up there
with just one of them right absolutely
they're both on it together and so both
of you guys being engaged what would you
encourage a couple out there maybe a guy
is listening right now because his wife
made him listen to this podcast and he's
like i don't know i don't want to do
this
what would you say to him you just gotta
ignore that side of your brain
and and just start get out of your
comfort zone try something new um engage
with your spouse about money because it
is crucial in a marriage to be on the
same page
and uh it's no longer your finances her
finances her thing your thing no it's
it's it's together so from this point on
i mean you guys gotta be on that same
sheet of music and for the encouragement
of that in your marriage would you say
your marriage is an even a better place
today because of that absolutely yeah
yeah yeah
absolutely yeah and now it's the wedding
gift that we give all the time
wow thank you
thank you very much i appreciate that no
thank you it makes shopping really easy
and and with him preaching that sermon
at that and that with those pipes i
think we'll just take a break next
second let him let him play the
microphone like the next segment i think
he's got the principles today media
voice is phenomenal
[Laughter]
very well done you guys
what was the hardest part
ooh um
i think when you would deploy just
staying in communication um and payment
fluctuates too with my job and his job
that those moments where you're not
together anymore just staying in line
and staying on top of it i think was
probably the more difficult moments we
had absolutely yeah very very hard yeah
wow way to go well we've got a copy of
the legacy journey for you you're on
your way to being baby steps
millionaires i love it thanks and that's
the next chapter in your story because
that's your whole thing you're going to
change
your legacy
and so legacy journey is a perfect book
to give you guys and also give you
another copy of the total money makeover
help you with shopping and uh you can
give that away and pay it pay it forward
and uh advise someone else that there's
a guy on the radio that anytime you need
to be mad at somebody who's your guy
he's your guy he can handle it i like
that that's fun very good very good
stuff
all right evan and jessica we're so
proud of you guys very very very well
done congratulations
136 thousand dollars paid off in three
years making 36 to 120 count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
three
two one
we're debt-free
[Applause]
i love it
amazing what a great couple i love it
it's the dinks dual income no kids and
they'd be on the way did it now now baby
maybe on the way baby baby is here here
we go this is how it's done that's fun
and uh you know incomes are going up and
and
isn't it weird though the process i
never get over the process that
all of us go through in our brain
when we make the decision what exactly
what what evan said
uh
you have to push yourself outside your
comfort zone you have to engage in
activities that you've never engaged in
if you want results you've never gotten
yep that's right if you keep doing the
same thing over and over again expect a
different result it's the definition of
insanity and that feels like a comfort
zone but it's also where things go to
die yeah well and to have hope that what
you're changing to is better
than your present right so like you know
it works like no one's stood on the
stage and screened i'm debt-free and
they're like i don't know i just don't
like it like i think we're gonna go get
a car loan you know i mean like you
don't feel that there's a level lifted
off like it works that's what happens
and so
when you do engage how does it feel oh
it's awful i'm going to get right back
as soon as i get out of here i don't
like it i think as soon as i get out of
here i'm going to the car like i don't
like it
so great but like
change though is hard you know you
haven't said it but i'm like yeah the
friction you know even um with my kids i
switched their car seats a few weeks ago
on accident and my three or my
four-year-old now would not get in her
car seat because on the other side of
the car
and i thought even a four-year-old
doesn't like change right like it's
uncomfortable people it is but the
moment you say you know what i'm going
to force myself to be uncomfortable for
a little bit because what i'm changing
to is better than my present it's worth
it
so everybody go home
change car seats
right now change it up
your kids your kids won't be happy
that's not what we're talking about
changing metaphors change is hard though
it's a great metaphor i like i like
those i like the teaching it's very good
because it's mike your grandkids of
course i like anything with my great
kids
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today
number one best-selling author and new
york times best-selling author of her
latest book know yourself know your
money you know we're talking about in
that last debt free screen being on the
same page with your spouse the know
yourself money assessment
is thirty dollars for a couple twenty
dollars for an individual it's great for
couples to get on the same page it takes
about 15 minutes and it delivers you
with 30 pages of personalized results
showing your money profiling beliefs
your money classrooms meaning how you
grew up your money tendencies your fears
your motivations your attitudes your
actions it's not all what you're doing
wrong it's what you do right and what
you do wrong and just your way of
looking at things and it gives you a
communication tool to work with your
spouse the know yourself
money assessment one of the more popular
things in the store at
ramseysolutions.com how many of you guys
are stressed out or hurting because your
retirement savings is scaring you with
all this stuff going on in the world
well you need to have someone in your
corner
to help you with this
you gotta have someone to walk with you
talk with you teach you
do you really have something to be
concerned about are you just in freak
out mode because sometimes we all got a
little drama queen inside of us right
and me too
so what we recommend is you have a
smartvestor pro in your corner we're not
in the investment business but we have
vetted
and
done detailed research on people who do
investing
out there do investing advice for you
investment brokers and these are people
with the heart of a teacher and they
agree with us on what we teach so you're
going to get similar and same advice so
click smart vester at
ramseysolutions.com or
hitramsolutions.com
smartvestor either one and um you can
find a list of the smartvestor pros in
your
area and one of them will sit down with
you and help you with your stuff
all right find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more they give us our
question of the day always use the promo
code ramsey to get the best possible
deal
today's question comes from whitney in
missouri
i'm a saver and my husband is a spender
we set up a budget when we got married
and included an allowance for each of us
to help monitor our spending he has been
reluctant and not a good follower of our
budget is having this allowance
something that you suggest if so how
much should we allot for our personal
spending and how do i fix
the issue of my husband going over the
set amount
oh man um
well a couple things whitney that stood
out in your question
we set a budget when we got married so
it's not like we said it last month so
i'm curious how long the discussion has
been how long you guys have been married
because the incur my encouragement would
be that you guys talk about it every
month
and
the allowance is it a good idea yeah the
word allowance is always weird for me
but i always say to have a personal line
item in your budget so for our family
for instance there's a rachel line item
there's a winston line item actually our
kids even have their own line items now
so i just know okay when we're spending
it like this is this is where it's
coming out of
um and that amount is going to depend on
your income and where you guys are in
the baby steps so
uh
how do i fix basically how do i fix my
husband well when you don't fix your
husband i'm sorry that doesn't it's not
how it works
uh you do have to
talk to him not preach at him but
come at these conversations in a way
that you can express what is going on in
you
whether it's frustration whether you're
scared whether you don't know what to do
whether it's you long for him to be more
involved i mean expressing these needs
in a way that is not um
putting him down right like i feel like
some
savers
which contend can be more of the nerds
in the relationship
can get very legalistic and it's this
way this way this way here's how much
money you have and when you do that to
your husband like the dynamic changes it
kind of goes from this like
marriage to
a mom to her son or something like it
gets weird so
um yeah like your language is that way
not yours rachel the person in the uh
giving him an allowance yeah whitney
this sounds like you're his mother yeah
you were to this not his not his wife
and so like he won't stick to his
allowance it's like oh my god what is
wrong so here's the thing you need to
sit down again and the two of you need
to decide what you want your future to
look like and what you're willing to do
to get to that future
instead of he needs to stick to his
allowance
he's a dadgum grown man he should stick
to his own allowance
because he wants to hit the goals that
he's agreed to
square your shoulders bubba man up here
okay that's not your mama this is your
wife and you're supposed to be part of
this team pulling the harness and so you
guys need to look out there in the
future together hold hands and go
there's where we want to go and here's
the price we're going to pay to get to
where we want to go and we both want to
get there so we're both going to pay
that price and that includes i'm going
to limit my personal spending to this
and you're going to limit your personal
spending to that and that's what we're
in agreement to not i'm going to be
you know schooling you up every time you
misbehave so the bottom line is i don't
think we did a budget i think you did a
budget and told him what it was
that's what it sounds like yeah yeah
and so i think he needs to get his butt
in gear and emotionally plug into
co-leading this household
this is your wife's son it's not your
mama
and so man up
and take take that take your share of
the responsibility and lady quit babying
him he's not your little boy
and that's the kind of thing that we're
talking about here now that's language
that people don't like in today's world
well go listen to another radio show
then because that's the way this really
this crap really works i've done this
for 30 years and so um
you know you guys can sit down there
together love each other love your
future
say gosh i'll do anything in the world
for you except stick to my allowance see
that that's the problem is the word
means that you allowed him to have a
certain amount of money and he didn't
stick to it right ain't your job to
allow him
it's our job to decide what we are going
to do yep that's the point that's the
way this stuff the the language in this
reveals it all yes and what happens so
many times in marriage when it comes to
money is the spouse becomes the enemy
right it's like well he he or she won't
oh and yeah there's issues there and in
a tactical way that if they are just
going and spending tons of money and
trying it i get that
but instead of seeing your spouse as the
enemy look at the things that are not
being done or look at the debt like like
have things out there that are the issue
and you guys lock arms together and look
at the problem your spouse isn't the
problem
um
yeah and you know you do a great job of
teaching about this on the budgeting
stuff in financial peace university this
idea that
and i forget the you do better with the
language than i do because i'm just kind
of mean about it but this this idea that
that um
both of you have to step up
and this i there's
a lot of people had model had parents
modeling for you and you took that model
and it was a bad model and they they
didn't mean to they weren't they weren't
bad people but um you know dad just
worked and he never looked at the money
and mama handled all the details
and mama paid the bills and so dad was
emotionally when it came to the
operation of the household yeah
subservient to his wife yeah or mom is
like well i don't know my husband takes
care of me i don't know what i mean and
she's over here and she's deficit and is
emotionally not plugged in and it's not
being a fully developed grown-up
in the situation both of you have to be
fully developed emotional mature
grown-ups pulling together for the same
goal when we see that we see people
change their lives absolutely that's
that's it that's well said because both
extremes
are not good you're not going to get it
on both extremes but this is not a
mansplaining thing no and it's not a
momsplaining thing no it's not trashing
your parents thing it's none of that
there's no victim or entitlement stuff
in here it's simply
you are not listen i'm not good with
money i just i let my wife handle and
she's so much smarter than me you're not
doing her a favor
you're not a blessing to her
and you even though you paid her a big
compliment she wishes she didn't have
all the weight of the decision making on
her shoulders
well my husband's really good with this
stuff his name is dave ramsey he knows
he tells everybody in america how to
handle money so i don't have to handle
money those words never left sharon
ramsey's mouth
she wants her vote to count she wants
her voice to be heard and and not in a
nagging way no but she is not
just take care of me i'm a little
southern belle and you just take it
she's not that woman yeah and because
she's like a full-grown mature woman you
know i mean oh my gosh this is what
we're talking about here both of you
step into this thing and then you'll go
win
well said this is the ramsey show
[Music]
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker just
tell alexa google assistant or siri to
play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america rachel cruz ramsey
personality new york times best-selling
author and my daughter
is my co-host open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
rachel's latest book know yourself know
your money new york times best seller is
all about how you discover why
you handle the money the way you do and
then what to do about it see we've
talked for 30 years around here what to
do now rachel's talking to you about why
you do some of the things you do that
are good
and some of them that you do that are
bad right yeah that's right but
understanding your motivations when it
comes to money
really explains your habits why you make
the decisions you make
all of that so it unpacks everything
from childhood
to tendencies to dreams to fears all of
it and it's
it's so it's so fascinating i love this
stuff i mean i love anything
self-discovery because i just think
we're complex people and you can kind of
get to the root of things you're like
that's why i do what i do you know and
it's it's i think it's always
fascinating so when you can grow
and learn from the roots it will help
you in all the things obviously that
we've you've taught for 30 years of the
how-to but a lot of this stuff you've i
mean
you've seen it like this book wasn't
a shock to you or surprised well no but
you took you took like you know i said
nerd or free spirit spender or saver
yeah and that's two of the constructs in
the entire book um but there's something
about um
it's like a ramsey pastime a family
thing that we really do enjoy trying to
figure out what makes people tick
why so-and-so is doing what they're
doing and how they do that and why and
then
and really so that's why we like
assessments that's why we like you know
disc and enneagram and strength finders
and the disc in fifth grade i couldn't
even read half the words i was like i
don't know what happened we're packing
and we're moving we found daniel's
your little brothers when he was 12.
disc profile just profile
what is it
he lied
he laughed about it no he laughed about
it because he said i didn't know what it
was and he said so i just answered all
the questions any old way and it's like
a straight line it's like he's nothing
oh funny and so now
we do know what he is now he's a very
high d very high bi yeah a lot like his
dad so but um
that's so
different on the enneagram though way
different on the enneagram but yeah yeah
so we've got these great assessments the
know yourself money assessment that
rachel and our incredible research team
have put together it it's thirty dollars
for a couple twenty dollars for an
individual what it does is it takes 15
minutes to take it it's and it spits out
30 pages of personalized results and it
talks about your money classrooms talk
about the money classrooms for a minute
because i think that's insightful uh
once you kind of know where you came
from it helps you know how to get where
you're going yeah absolutely well
there's two ways money was communicated
in your home growing up verbally what
was said and then emotionally what it
was felt in the home right the
environment and so it creates kind of
this quadrant
and so that first money classroom is the
anxious money classroom and this is if
your home was verbally closed so money
was not talked about but emotionally
stressed so if you grew up in this
household it was the feeling like at the
end of the month you just felt tension
around you didn't you know you didn't
really know but oh you just felt it in
the air didn't dare bring it up no
classroom two is the unstable money
classroom this is where it's verbally
open it is talked about but it's
emotionally stressed so conflict
fighting you heard your parents have the
same money fight possibly over and over
again
uh it was there and then classroom three
is the unaware money classroom and this
is where it's verbally closed it's not
talked about but it's emotionally calm
so i always say with this classroom if
you grew up you probably were one of the
ones that left home at like 1821 and you
thought i know nothing about money and
oh it's oh it is a big deal okay i gotta
i gotta figure this out because no one
talked about it and it just didn't seem
like a big deal it's just like that's
just what it is and then classroom four
is probably the healthiest it is the
healthiest money classroom and that's
where it's verbally open and emotionally
calm
so money is talked about it's not taboo
you're engaged in conversations from
tactical things like what a 401k is to
more you know emotional things like um
generosity and contentment and the value
money plays in our life right like that
was just talked about but it was also
calm because there was a plan probably
around money there was a level of yep we
know what we're doing
you could have cooperation collaboration
between the parents yeah yeah i mean and
and in that classroom you don't have to
have a million dollars right you can you
can you you don't have to be wealthy in
that classroom by any means either so so
just kind of knowing what i found in all
the research when i was writing about
this is
people either really mirrored what they
knew growing up so if we didn't talk
about money i just won't talk about
money either like i'll just shut it down
or people did the exact opposite so i've
heard many people say yeah my parents
fought all the time about money so it's
not worth it it's not worth engaging in
a conversation it's not worth the fight
we'll just figure it out and i don't
want to go there um or my parents never
talk to us about money and you hear
someone say so now i'm like constantly
on my kids to be like you have to learn
this stuff so it's just interesting to
see people
again you either just mirror what you
know without realizing it
or people just did the exact opposite
but i think that it shapes you
and just that's the foundation that's
laid that i mean any any therapist would
say your household growing up was your
classroom to life it's where you learned
life's lessons and same with money and
so
this is where you learned it and you got
to figure out what lessons you want to
take with you into adulthood what
lessons you wish you could probably
unlearn all of it but it's it's
interesting to kind of go back there and
say okay this is it and as well i have
this
if you have siblings
ask your siblings what kind of classroom
they felt like they grew up in because
even depending on your personality you
could have a
a perspective of one classroom and your
sibling has another of how they
saw things or or understood things so
yeah you were born the year we filed
bankruptcy so when ours was an unstable
yeah
freaked out
losing everything classroom you were too
small to to know it your sister was a
toddler
probably also too small but might have
you know distant memories somewhere deep
down in her psyche of that but
you know so our family went through a
shift yes which happens we went through
from you know being a meltdown
disastrous mess
me and your mom up to by the time you
were old enough to know
it was pretty calm and organized and
methodical because we were already doing
this stuff and teaching this stuff
absolutely yep for sure for sure and so
like you know you you were doing the
writing for this and you said well i
grew up in a very calm and stable and
and we're like yeah you just weren't old
enough to remember when it wasn't yeah
that's all i know i had the manuscript
we had dinner and i was like here's what
i'm writing about and i feel like you
know it was this i feel like it was
classroom four for the most part and
you're like yeah because you're too
young to remember classroom two
unstable it was crazy
when we were nuts
oh yeah it can still get there
we can get there we just don't live
there
we can drive by now and say hi
but that's all
oh my gosh yeah this stuff is so
valuable though to know where you come
from and you get and then you look at
your spouse and you go oh
you have a little bit of empathy for
them
when you know kind of okay that's where
you came from oh you're
more of an abundance versus scarcity and
i'm kind of scarcity oh you're more
saver i'm more spender oh you like to
spend on experiences you like to spend
on things yeah it's winston as biggest
rub yup yup i want to go to disney
rachel the kids aren't listening 100
would spend a hundred percent of our
money on experiences i just take
vacations all day long 100 percent and
what i want to spend on disney what
sounds like eating out has nothing to do
with the food
it's the entertainment appetite it's the
entertainment it's who's going and the
dessert and the decaf coffee desserts i
did a two and a half hour dinner when
when winston when you asked once about
rachel he says rachel's a fun girl he
said you make me more fun he just said
that to me yesterday
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality
number one best-selling author new york
times bestselling author of her last and
latest book not our last book but our
latest book
know yourself know your money my co-host
today open phones a triple eight eight
two five five two two five shelley's in
destin florida hi shelly how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
well i just need some advice me and my
husband have been paying off her debt
we're down to one last credit card um it
totals out to be 10
596.90
and um we're thinking about borrowing it
from the 401k we don't have much in
there we have around 21 000 in our 401k
and we're just trying to make the best
choice
uh the credit cards at a 24 interest
so i just need some advice how much was
the total of the credit card did you say
ten thousand
ten thousand five hundred ninety six
dollars okay ninety cents yeah
okay
what's your household income
51
okay
all right how long have you been
listening to this show
um i've heard about you guys through
church members
and
i just actually signed up for your
your classes
and your apps that you'll have yes i
just did that um i'm just really excited
to get
out of debt because i mean we did cash
advances and all kinds of things and we
paid off probably over a hundred
thousand wow
i'm dead yeah
you're tired you're tired of the fear
and the chaos aren't you
yes i am and just living from paycheck
to paycheck
you know not knowing what's going to
come next
my husband oh he's so on board with
getting out of debt
um it stresses him out a lot you know
just being all that responsibility on
him
and so um and plus i want him to be able
to retire at us at a nice age to enjoy
you know everything and to line our
lives up you know biblically with the
bible that's the most important thing so
you guys are sweet people
you're sweet well thank you um
well i'm glad that you're plugged into
ramsey plus and into financial peace
university we'll walk you through
rachel and i are two of the main
teachers in the in those videos that
you're going to go through
and we're going to show you how to get
on a budget which is going to help you
get out of the payday advanced stuff
because that comes from
not planning well when you start doing
your budget you're going to hear us say
it again on the videos but you'll feel
like you've got a raise
because being out of control makes you
it makes you
make wrong decisions i've been there too
i know how it feels i've done it too
okay
um
and here's the thing you're going to be
able to pay off the credit card
so fast
if you follow the stuff that we teach in
detail and both you and your husband are
doing it that the interest rate's not
going to matter much
okay because you're going to pay it off
in under a year
okay probably under six months
because you're not going to do anything
to pay off this credit card we're going
to teach you to get so focused on it
because you're sick of it and the great
news about where you are the way you're
speaking about this you're doing it with
such an open hand
and um
it's almost kind of tender just
listening to you that you are you're at
the perfect place you're like just teach
me just show me how i'm just sick of it
i'll do anything and that's what i keep
hearing from you and so what that tells
me having done this for 30 years is
you're going to have great success in
the next 12 months it's going to blow
your mind where you are by next summer
don't you think rachel yeah well i was
going to say shelly i mean
from how you guys have been living to
what you're about to engage in and
actually get a plan and we said this in
an earlier segment you know but the
there'll be changes you'll do stuff
that's different than you've ever done
before and it's going to first feel
uncomfortable
but push through that because
immediately when you start to live on a
budget and it works you know you are in
control of your money versus your money
controlling you you have a plan you and
your husband are on the same page you're
working toward the same goal i mean all
of that is so cohesive when it works
and it's an amazing thing like you will
never
experience the level of control that
you're about to have and and yep and
he's exactly right i'm like yeah there's
no need to take out a 401k loan at all
don't do it don't do that um when you
guys start to do the math and you start
to see okay here's where our money can
go
you're gonna you're gonna pay it off
you're going to be able to do this
yeah interest rate matters if you're
going to keep the debt around for five
years
but when you're going to keep it around
for six months or seven months or
whatever you end up with is ten thousand
dollars it's not gonna it's not gonna
matter much the second thing is you
never borrow in any circumstance for all
you listeners out there on a 401k here's
why you unplug
in her case half of your 401k ten
thousand of his 20 000 that's invested
is now unplugged from good investments
making 10 or 12 percent in good mutual
funds and instead you pay yourself back
five percent or six percent or seven
percent or however it's set up it's one
of those three numbers
and um
so you you're trading off for a bad a
bad rate of return so it is costing you
more than it appears to be costing you
the second thing is when you leave your
company and you will leave your company
you will die
you will get a better job or you will
get fired one of the three ways you will
leave your company when you leave your
company not if
your 401k loan
is considered by the irs in early
withdrawal and you have 60 days to
completely repay it oh by the way you
just don't have a job anymore
but you have 60 days to repay the loan
or it's considered an early withdrawal
and you're taxed and penalized on it
so it's a disaster looking for a place
to happen so never borrow on a 401k
now that's
that's a sidebar really because shelly
your story is so much bigger
than just the ten thousand dollars
because you're going to such really
really really good places i'm so proud
of you all right dylan is with us in
springfield mass hey dylan what's up
hey how's it going dave better than i
deserve how can we help sir
uh well i'm 25 i make about 80 grand a
year uh i got 420 bucks a month in
expenses i'm currently debt-free minus
my 401k loan that you're just talking
about
um i'm currently living with my
grandmother right now um i got 22 000 in
savings and i want to buy a house but
like i'm not real sure where to go from
here or what to do with the market the
way it is and all the houses around me
are pretty expensive so i'm just not
super sure what to do cool yeah it's a
great question how much is your 401k
loan
uh i think there's about eight left on
it okay write a check today and pay it
off
okay
and now we've got not 22 but now we have
14.
but you make 80 and you got no bills
because you live with your grandmother
right so you pile up money pretty fast
can't you
right minus the expenses because i kind
of take care of her too with you know
groceries and all this stuff yeah well
what i would encourage you dylan is to
figure out what your expenses are per
month
and then get an emergency fund of three
to six months worth of that have that
just cash in the bank which again that
18 it's gonna it's going to help you the
14.
um that's left in your savings will be a
good jump start if not completed
depending on again what your expenses
are um and then from there is what we
call baby step three b
and that is where you're gonna save up
for your down payment on your home
and that's you want to save up at least
10 to 20 percent
and then the formula we always use is
that your take home your your payment is
no more than 25 of your take-home pay on
a 15-year fixed rate
now that's to say if you want to buy a
home and i don't know your situation uh
are you single
yeah yeah is is buying a home something
you want to do or you do you want to
rent for a little bit do you want to
stay with your grandmother like what are
you what do you want to do
i'd like to buy a house okay i had one
already i sold a year ago gotcha because
of uh
they built houses right on top of mine
so i sold mine but yep i do
one house yeah yeah yeah so yeah when
you get to that point that you have that
down payment saved up
um then i think it's then it's a great
time i mean you're gonna you're in a
good position obviously you're gonna be
completely debt free by this afternoon
because you're gonna write a check and
get that taken care of
uh and you have some good savings you
can save up a little bit more but that
um that down payment savings will be
your next your next step
good work brother good work the question
you gotta ask it sounds like more than
anything is just how long do you need to
be there and want to be there
to uh take care of your grandmother in
this situation
and um you know
it's working for now uh is that a
three-year plan a three-month plan
five-year plan and then that'll help you
answer when you're ready to buy but yeah
get out of debt build your emergency
fund and save your down payment like
rachel laid out that's exactly
what we teach
this is the ramsey shot
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
joshua and anna are with us hey guys how
are you hi
well i'm water now that we see you good
to have you
thank you for having us well we're
honored to have you thank you for being
here and where do you guys live new
jersey in jersey and all the way to
nashville to do a debt-free scream
that's right how much did you pay off 70
437 in 10 months
and your range of income during that
time uh it started at 102 and aid has
ended now in 202.
all right what do you guys do for a
living i am an icu nurse
and i'm an audio tech all right wow you
guys are killing it way to go
very good what kind of debt was this 70
000
oh my gosh it was um it was a car
payment
it was a student loan debt and it was
credit cards
30 000 and student loans 9 000 in cards
and the rest um was the car so you guys
were just normal yeah we were yeah
so i mean it not not going well at all
but kind of felt like normal yeah it's
just the way everybody is right normal
just a little too long though
i hear you so uh what happened a year
ago they got you guys fired up and doing
this ramsey stuff this started um in
january well we've been together since i
was 17 and he was
um actually longer than that we were
together since high school so we had our
oldest daughter when we were really
young and um all we've known is work and
struggle and that
for
20 years
it's going to be 13 years since we've
been married this september so
back in 2019 in january we went to a
marriage conference
in king's way church in cherry hill and
they had a clinic about finances and
anita and steve jenka
if you guys are watching they were the
ones that touched base on the finances
and talked about fpu
and that's when the light bulb went out
for us
you thought maybe it doesn't have to be
struggle all the time yes well
it went a little bit further we had some
savings
that exceeded the amount of debt but
they were savings we you know trying to
accumulate you know for the for the kids
whatever
and somehow just not being reckless and
just thinking that the harder you work
the you know just with hard hard work
hard work hard work well
we weren't budgeting we weren't paying
attention to our finances and it was
just work work work work work work work
chaotic
hectic lifestyle
um and you feel like a rat in the wheel
oh it disappeared right it just
disappeared the money disappeared yeah
oh yeah yeah
you had a leak yeah
no it wasn't material things it was just
no big item stuff will come up and it's
like take a thousand here or whatever
yeah
yep wow and so then you've got all that
regret
which tastes really nasty on the back of
your tongue extremely we almost i mean i
lost it you know um it was towards the
end of 19.
september 2009 i lost it i said this is
this is it i'm done with the struggle
i'm just had it i i'm not living like
this anymore no no i i said i like this
guy i'd rather go on my own i said i
told my wife i said if i'm gonna
struggle i'll just move into a room you
can have everything i said but i can't
continue i'm gonna i'm gonna drive
myself into the grave um
and it was just so then you go to the
marriage conference and financial peace
university and you say i gotta go to
that class and they started it in
september of 2019. oh yes so we we heard
about it january we started the class
september 2019 fpu and um it was hard
because every time we watched those
videos it would just be like a slap in
the face
like dave is calling me stupid again yes
and it was hard on us because every time
we tried to sit down and have a budget
meeting it was fights because we could
not believe when we added up 70 000
we were like we're gonna be dead by the
time we get this paid off it's never
going to happen we were hopeless that's
the the right word and um and you know
when did that turn
when did they when did it turn from
hopeless to hopeful um after the life
group you know just having that sense of
community
and seeing people from all different
kinds of walk of life you know so the
other people in the financial peace
university yeah yeah there was there was
a doctor in there yeah it was you know
you don't feel so dumb because
everybody's no no not at all you know
that's when it like sank in okay well
maybe we can do this yeah okay and then
covet hit
yep and you're a nurse yes i see you
nurse i see a nurse and it gets better
it gets better covet hit and i'm just as
i'm starting my 2020 season
um because i work for the union so it's
all theatrical
and mainstream production so live well
the first whiff was all the
pharmaceutical trade shows and
conferences were canceled okay that's
not good
then when live nation did their release
you know they canceled the whole touring
season yep that was like oh my goodness
and i'm like now this couldn't get any
you know we gained some momentum from
2019 we got the rhythm down we got you
know so
were you working all the time though so
what happened was when covet hit he lost
his job because there was no concerns
now no event and he was like i can't i
can't stay home like i have to go and
find a job and i said to him listen
i'm an icu nurse i can't escape this we
have no idea what's going on we have no
idea how you know what's happening what
we know is that it's bad so and we had
just actually gotten our sander
insurance life policy we had just gotten
it approved in january right before
covert hit so i told them the girls
don't need to lose to parents you know
you stay home you take care of the girls
you help them with homeschooling and you
stay safe and we i will go on our work
and he wasn't too happy about it but i'm
like i'm doing it i'm not gonna have you
out there risking your life for pennies
on the dollar you know compared to what
he was making before so just stay home
you got like triple time so i was
working six days a week 13 14 hour
shifts yeah your pay went through the
roof and so i was working my full-time
job uh
and then i went to travel nursing so i
was working three days a week around
home and i was working i know three days
a week up north about an hour so you
might you made a couple of hundred that
year yeah yeah
and so i was living in a trailer outside
of my house because i was scared to get
you know get them sick and stuff it was
a little rough in the beginning but
you know we saw we saw our opportunity
to be gazelle intense and that's what i
did and and i just want to thank you
guys because you know unknowingly you
and rachel and all the ramsey
personalities and all the callers were
the ones that kept me going so on my
drives up north you know all my long
nights and my long mornings i would
listen to all the podcasts and that's
what would keep me going you know not
being able to see my family not be able
to be with them it was really hard on
them it was really hard on me but we
were just focused we were zeroed in on
being debt-free because we got tired of
being tired of being tired well you took
a really hard scary
situation and the work you did thank you
for all the work throughout this um this
time
and you took and you said okay what can
i do how can i better my family and this
and this hard time and then you guys
together
made that decision and it's amazing and
when you thought you guys are never
gonna be the same that's so awesome oh
no
you're right so awesome it's like every
time i gotta fork out something i don't
want mine i don't wanna i don't wanna
spend that much well not only that yeah
but it's not only that but i mean that
hopeless chaotic we're stuck in a rut
we'll never get out you're never going
to think that way again the rest of your
life your brain has been stretched to a
different level you'll never you can't
go back to the same shape people think
we're crazy like oh you are you're
awesome at work they're like why are you
working so much it was a campaign that
like i work around with my budget
everywhere i go and i show it to all my
nurse friends i show it to everyone i
talk to my patients about it i'm very
very we're very passionate about it
awesome last thing i'm worried about is
what you care whether you care about it
that's awesome
you are amazing this is such a great
story we've got a copy of the total
money makeover for you in the legacy
journey for you the legacy journey is
the next step chapter in your story
because you guys have completely changed
your whole lives yes
so impressed you're amazing wow thank
you guys man oh man we are so so
grateful you have no idea wow wow i feel
like you just came through a war
man amazing wow all right joshua and
anna
leah and
melania melania ah beautiful name sorry
i was about to mess it up there and 70
thousand dollars paid off but boy oh boy
oh boy in 10 months making 102 to 202
never be the same again this family
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream are you guys you guys ready yep
three
two
one
we are free
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for joining us america
our scripture of the day jeremiah 32 17
o sovereign lord you have made the
heavens and the earth by your great
power and outstretched arm
nothing is too hard for you
arnold palmer said always make a total
effort
even when the odds are against you
now you hear us by the way talk about
term life insurance all the time guys
that's because term life insurance can
make all the difference financially for
your family
if god forbid something happens to you
you heard that last couple say uh you
know we're facing these really scary
unknowns with kovad you remember when we
all didn't know anything about covet
uh and most of us admitted it back then
um but uh man
that family went and got life insurance
didn't they that's what they said and
they had gotten it before covet all
started right
our term life calculator makes it easy
for you to find the right policy it
shows you how much coverage you'll need
and it takes less than five minutes to
get your numbers here's what to expect
first answer a few questions give us a
snapshot of your life the free
calculator will then tell you how much
coverage you need it's usually about 10
to 12 times your annual income
and how long you need to keep the
insurance and then you'll be able to
compare rates and select the best policy
through xander our trusted partner they
shop over a dozen insurance carriers
help you find the best deal to get your
results text term life to 33 789 we'll
help you with the term life calculator
it's very easy
text term life two three three
seven
eight nine and you can make sure
that your family is taken care of
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five rachel cruz
ramsey personality best-selling author
and my daughter is my co-host today
josh is with us in chattanooga hi josh
what's up
i'm dan gray how you doing dave better
than i deserve how can i help
well i've got i've always been an
employee and here recently my i've had a
youtube channel that has really taken
off
and i'm starting to get paid from that
and i'm not sure i have people telling
me i need like a you know business
license or llc where i can write off the
expenses but i'm not sure if i really
need that
wow good for you
what kind of money you making off of
youtube uh well like this week i made
900 off youtube so it's i mean it's
trending up real fast but like this week
i made 900 bucks so it's doing really
well so if that continues you might make
50 60 grand a year or more
yeah that's what i'm hoping what's your
channel about josh i'm just curious
i get old cars running i've been sitting
20 30 years the channel sleeper dude
okay yeah hmm
very cool
you'd like it dave i think i would i'm a
bit of a gearhead i think i'd like
watching you what's it called again i'll
look it up
sleeper dude all one word i'll be
looking for your comments sleeper
dude as in as in take a nap sleep oh
it's the car's a sleeper car oh okay
no i understand okay cool well we just
told 22 million people so hopefully
we'll get your youtube revs up
all right but um great yeah anyway
anyway um
for those of you that don't know the
more viewers you have on youtube once
you reach a certain point they will
actually start paying you because the
ads that they run on your youtube
video they make money on and they share
a little of it with you not much but a
little
and uh so he's if he's getting 900 a
week off of this he's got quite a good
viewership it's uh you don't get that
with 500 of your friends looking on it's
it's tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands to get to that point so very
cool we make a little money on youtube
too but uh here's the thing you you do
not need an llc unless you want one you
what you do want to do is open a
separate
business checking account
and uh put all of your youtube revenues
or any other money you make on this
endeavor if you bought a car and sold it
as a part of the business or something
like that you would put any money you
make into that account and you the only
thing you write out of that account
are business expenses
okay and so if you bought uh some video
equipment if you bought some tools to
work on the cars
anything like that you're doing that's
associated with the business that would
be a business expense needs to come out
of that account and so if you put all
the income of the business into that
account and the only thing you take out
of that account are business expenses by
definition what's left in there is your
profit right okay revenue minus expenses
is profit now then if you take some of
the profit home
you'll pay taxes on it i'll come back to
that in a minute all right but if you
take that the information in your
checking account the income
and the expenses
and you sit down to do your taxes you
can do it as a sole proprietor on
schedule c or you can have a tax
preparer do it or you can
incorporate it into an llc if you want
to it's not necessary for you to write
it off though you can write it off as a
sole proprietor and not have to open up
something the only reason you really
need an llc is if you're afraid of being
sued for something
okay yeah i wouldn't be worried about
that really not not not yet you get a
big enough number on this some idiot
will figure out a way to sue you but um
yeah but but but in the meantime uh
right now 50 grand is not a big enough
target on your butt you don't have to
worry about it but you start cranking
off three or four hundred on this go
ahead and get an llc okay
is there like a percentage i should save
back for taxes exactly that's my next
that's my next speech
so um
when you take money out of this business
account
that we just opened josh's sleeper cars
or with sleeper dudes or whatever this
kind of thing right the sleeper dude
account when you take money out of it
and bring it home
i want you to set aside a fourth of that
into a separate savings account for
taxes
okay because you're supposed to pay
quarterly estimates on your business to
the irs now the quarterly estimate is a
one-page form
that shows the revenues for the quarter
the expenses for the quarter there for
the profit for the quarter and then
estimate your tax based on that profit
and you're supposed to send them that
amount of money which will be about a
fourth of this it'll be very close
okay
all right great when you so when you
calculate that now the cool thing is
when you go to fill out your quarterly
estimates if you've set aside a fourth
of your profit
out of this account any money you take
out of this account so you pull a
thousand bucks out of this account you
write 250 over into the tax savings
account for your quarterlies and you
write 750 into your personal account to
spend buy groceries with
yeah okay
and that's that's the process so
set us out of fourth until you get to
making oh more than a hundred and
hundred and something then you'll have
to go a little more than a fourth
but for right now i think and that's
profit not gross so for right now i
think a fourth will be very very close
for you uh so really two big things one
is a separate checking account that
gives you your profit and then when you
take money out the separate savings
account to pay your taxes you're
withholding on yourself is what you're
doing does that make sense to you
that makes sense
very cool congratulations man i'm proud
of you that's a neat thing it's fun when
you kind of stumble into something you
know and he's like oh wow i get to make
videos something i love
and i'm making 900 bucks a week it's fun
there's guys and gals doing stuff on
youtube that are making serious
money i mean our friend our friends
tyler in the game the dude perfect guys
they are they've been killing it for
years uh and sharp sharp young men but i
mean they're the top five six youtube
channels in the world they're huge and
so they're making a lot more than 900 a
week on that uh to say the least like a
lot of zeros but
and good because they're what they're
doing is good clean fun and it's
entertaining families love it families
the kids love it and it's just an
incredible youtube channel we had them
speak at uh our entree leadership summit
down in dallas the other day when we
were down there just great guys yep yep
great guys and so you know there's this
youtube thing is um
uh there there's some serious uh players
in it just social media i'm like people
have large instagram accounts and there
may i mean like they it's well the
influencers is a different crowd yes
but the youtube crowd is is uh some of
those are influencer types too yeah but
some of them are actually content you
know they're actually have content
they're actually providing entertainment
or they're providing instruction on
something or whatever and it's going
beautifully and um you know our show of
course this show is broadcast every day
on youtube yep and so and it's got a
huge following thank you guys on thank
you to the like the youtube people call
themselves the youtube crazies hello
thanks youtube crazies we appreciate you
being there
all right that puts us this hour of the
ramsey show in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ jesus
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you